[Musique]
il ya un petit peu de l'histoire qui me
concerne 2 ou 3 et après sinon c'est des
amis ma mère aussi a participé et j'ai
fait un appel à témoin sur les réseaux
sociaux donc j'ai également des gens que
je connais pas du tout qui ont bien
voulu témoigner donc ça c'est assez
chouette c'est un peu un truc de
référence pour à la fois que les gens
puissent apprendre ou se reconnaître
dedans et à la fois dédramatiser un peu
le fait que je vais traiter avec humour
c'est pour que c'est quand même pas trop
trop grave
après bon je dis pas qu'il ya des choses
qu'on regarde ce qui se passe des fois
ça doit arriver mais voilà c'était pour
détendre un peu les gens autour de
sujets il ya une personne qui a envoyé
son frère jumeau à sa place parce que en
fait ils assument et plus du tout et il
a perdu son courage avant d'aller au
rendez vous puis des trucs aussi de deux
dents un rendez vous entre deux
personnes et puis là il ya la personne
avec qui l'une des deux est en couple
depuis sept ans qui débarque alors que
le parti défait du tout au courant